thì bà này thì thay trời các bạn có rất nhiều bạn,
nó có kết khăn nhau những tuy nhiên,
nhớ như bạn nào đã dần nhận đi các khác,
thật trở nên các bạn thì thay trời nghĩa các bạn sẽ 1 trộng cách,
nằm rất nâng nhé, và quan trọng, và kết kiệm thử dân.
Và các bạn còn có đồ chính xác rất cao trong những cách nằm này,
tại vì thương thường như bây giờ này thì cách nằm này nó rất nhiều qua.
Nhà thì thay vọng, sau kể bài này thì các bạn muốn đã tiếp tù lực các kia kia kinh thức bộ e kỳ để các bạn rất giết kỳ trong khoa.
Các bạn có thể thăm xác phó, có thể đất.
Hó các bạn có thể xem tuy nhiên, có thể đất thì đều có những kỳ,
khiến thất về xa đồ để khác, cũng tuyết các sợ dành.